Alex oh it's weird for merchants would
you drug Oh cargo Illinois it's my town
really yeah it's awesome and how are you
been out here exactly
October 10th was just one year most of
yours you're fairly new here exactly
tell me childhood you grew up with both
parents okay um I grew up my parents
were together - about the age of like
just about 10 and they separated my mom
moved to New Jersey and my dad went to
Miami Florida and now you know I was
upset about with them you know and they
split and taking me for my friends so I
kind of refused to leave so I stayed
there with my aunt and I just kind of
bounced around from Chicago to New
Jersey to Miami
like when I caused enough trouble I'm
sending it to your mother's you know me
when I'm go causing hurt oh wow you're
going to your father so now I go to
Chicago so it was just I was uh I was
able to run while for a few years you
know ten years old yeah yeah well until
that went on for a while and then after
he went to high school yeah went to high
school high school where'd you go
that's where everything kinda got a
little wild in my life um I went to
Miami and I met some family I didn't
know I had like my mom she did
everything she could my whole childhood
to keep me away from like immediate
uncles and stuff I and I didn't
understand at first but then I realized
why she wanted to keep me away from them
and then she realized that you know I
mean they couldn't do that anymore I
mean how was how does it go can I get in
do you want me to tell you about that
like well I met them yeah it's actually
wild story man I was uh
I flew went to Miami International I was
like 17 18 just finished high school and
my I haven't seen my dad in a few years
and he picked me up in the airport
ma some guys driving Porsche Cayenne six
hours late picked me up so this guy's
driving the cars two girls in the car
later find out they're both strippers my
dad stood in the backseat he's got a
girl there an old bunch it yeah-yo on
the thing I'm just like oh my god this
you know this is wow that I was going
down there kind of get sober stuff you
know and I immediately saw that's not
where this is going right so he gets my
dad's condos in Sunny Isles Beach my
answer David Cote yeah I mean he was off
the chain he was more like my best
friend like a brother like we partied
like so anyways I walk into his condo I
the light switch on all of a sudden a
hand comes over my hand knocks my hand
all the way lights go down two people
picked me up
they got bandanas over their face slam
me on the ground pulled out a gun put a
gun in my mouth you point the gun down
like this and they're screaming at me
punching me hitting me all kinds of
stuff and I just remember like I'm said
laying on the ground like this and I
could see my dad and he's walking out
the room and like the last look like I
didn't say anything at he look he just
kind of looks at me like this he turned
his head and he walked out the door at
that moment I was like I might die right
now you know I mean like what's going on
right so they're asking me questions hit
me with the gun all kinds of stuff and
next thing I know another light comes on
they take things off their face pick me
up hug and kiss me how you doing I'm
your uncle Joey I'm your Uncle Jimmy I'm
your I'm your cousin Joey and I'm like
what the [ __ ] going on and I was like
they wanted to see what I was made out
of like am I gonna cry am I gonna go to
the police am I gonna beg for my life
you know say like and I was just like
you it was just so many emotions came
over me it was like you know it was
crazy and that's when it was wild down
there I ended up in federal prison I
just did like seven years for a bank
robbery Shh unreal yeah so you're doing
code there wild yeah he was he was off
the chain my uncle's he's dead now but
he was connected down there big-time I
mean I used to write it was crazy what
age were you when you first started
using drugs I was in rehab when I was 15
15 15 I struggled struggled early we
knew was oxycottons when I was like
first time I shot put in needle my arm I
was 14 years old
and that was actually my dad knew those
heroin yeah you know I was doing heroin
but he had like morphine 100's and
oxycottons he would get me and
at first I was kind of mad at him you
know I mean like inside like I did it
with him but like I was kind of mad at
him you know I mean cause it was like I
kind of wanted subconsciously I wanted
him to tell me not to do it cuz it was
like that would be proof that he loved
me but then I thought maybe he was
giving him to me because he knew I would
go out and get it on my own
and he wouldn't be around so maybe he
thought it was safer and so I kind of
just played these scenarios over my head
you know I mean why and then I just kind
of realized that I mean my brother and
sister don't talk to him they haven't
talked to him since they were little
kids they refused to you I mean no phone
calls no contact and it was like he
would do anything just so he didn't lose
I guess the last person and his family
maybe you know I mean because it's like
my mom doesn't talk to him nobody and it
was like you know yeah it's my pops that
I have 100% loyal you don't mean it's my
pops
my girlfriend sleeps with her with him
she's the [ __ ] she's gone I don't care
that's my dad he can't he can do no
wrong you know I mean don't tell me
otherwise you know I'm saying that's my
dad
I don't care and I think he took that he
used it he used it to get what he wanted
he used it for his own addiction and I
know he loves me as best as he could you
know what I mean so I mean
when dad came home and all of our stuff
is outside of the condo and I'm like
what's going on
he's like sweating drinking drinking
drinking drinking drinking drinking
crazy and he drinks beer he pops pills
right so but he's drinking the hard
liquor and I'm like so something's wrong
you know I mean his dad drank a lot of
hard liquor he beat the [ __ ] out of him
all times so he didn't like her liquor
he didn't like me drinking hard liquor
I could take morphine and he was okay
but if I drink hard liquor that was a
deal breaker you know and I'm like so
what's going on well what are you doing
where we going and car pulls up you know
he doesn't answer me he's ignoring me
and he gets in the car knee leaves you
know me some of the stuff and I was
basically on my own I mean what did you
nineteen
and
I was banging our credit I was doing
credit cards down there so I mean
basically I was on my own at this point
Miami Florida and uh I met somebody at
the casino and he had just done in 15
years in prison his father told on
somebody he actually was the head of
might be the Lucchese fearsome like one
of the five families out on the East
Coast in New York his father actually
ran it at one point and then got in
trouble flipped and got 190 people
indicted in federal prison 190 people
were indicted cuz of this man so he's in
witness protection program somewhere
else right and the son is this guy I
mean and I didn't know who he was at
first and we were just doing a little
business here and there and then I
realized just the way people look at him
and talk to him I'm like is this guy
Xena movies is you know I mean it's like
he belongs in the movies I'm telling you
he's off the chain and I learned who he
was and uh he's he had a hard life
because of his dad you know I mean I
feel we related a lot and he taught me a
lot I mean stuff that's gonna get you
paid I mean nothing that's really gonna
help you out or help society you know I
mean just kind of contaminating
everything but he was a good guy you
know I mean he looked out for me and the
bottom line is like I was fed and I had
a place to sleep and I had money in my
pocket you know
and sometimes at the end of the day
that's that's all I'm going for you know
what I mean it's like I don't I don't
want to do damage to people I just want
to UM just want to survive and be happy
you know just depending on how you look
at life some people look at life like
they need money to me
my success is about experience memories
knowledge that's what's important that's
what's gonna matter you know what I mean
when I'm laying on my deathbed I don't
want to look at my bank account I want
to look back and say god damn
[ __ ] you went hard you gave it
everything you learned the good memories
bad memories it doesn't matter that's
what it's about
you know hold it just turn 30 young
still feels like I feel like I'm young
but I feel like I'm old too how do you
I got it I got in a little trouble I
owed some I owed some money I had a
couple prescriptions and each one cost
like 2,500 bucks and I got him fronted
to me cuz I was about to go get rid of
them I lived with these three girls
Kaylee Roxy and Lauren one was from
Dallas Texas the other one - were from
Little Rock Arkansas I met these girls
they lived in the same condo as my dad
and I went out early one morning to go
smoke a cigarette and one of the girls
has markers all over her and it looks
actually sleeping and I kind of just
walked by and I laughed is it gosh she
had a wild night and then I I'm hearing
like a noise come out of her and I'm
like what the [ __ ] was that noise and I
looked in like crap
her cheeks are swollen and stuff and
she's like moaning and I realized she
got beat up somebody beat her up raped
her and they drew all over her like [ __ ]
this and that like it wasn't it was
[ __ ] up and that's when I realized
there was something wrong with her and
so I I I knew where her room was I'd
have a phone on me or nothing so I just
kind of picked her up and I carried her
up to the room and I knocked on the door
and the girls are in the room Franek
on the phone they could tell they're all
[ __ ] coked up and they're all you
know I mean but they're like looking for
her and I called the door they
immediately hang up the phones all we
found her we found her this net and
that's how I became friends with them I
mean they were a Wild Bunch - they came
they came out to Hollywood Florida to
get into the movies I'm like you girls
came to the wrong coast so basic you
know I mean girls come travel halfway
across the country leave home to go and
up in movies but what do they end up in
the titty bar selling some ass you know
I mean it's inevitable it happened you
know I mean it's it's like and I ended
up living with them and they were going
like man that was an awesome time of my
life I swear to God I remember one time
moment I'm at the Jade Alfa Collins
Avenue
penthouse all the way on the top and I
got a bottle of Johnnie Walker Blue
Label sitting there a bucket eyes
rolling a blunt of some weed and I'm on
the balcony looking down at the ocean I
remember I turned my chair around and I
look inside and I used to go out where
they do private dances so they don't get
beat up no more like I kind of someone
on security like not as like a pimp but
life just as their friend you know what
I mean and I kind of handled all their
financials for them everything because I
mean they were off the chain they wanted
to have fun but they were getting
screwed over I mean they were making so
much money but they were getting screwed
by everybody you know what I mean and
when I came around that stopped and we
were just having fun like they'd come
home and have $1,500 each that night so
I could get and now it's a coke pound of
weed promethazine pills xanax go pay the
rent everything's handled it's all
beautiful you know me and we just run
around Miami like a wild bunch but I'll
never forget that night I turn around
you know I mean I'm drinking this
whiskey you know look these girls are
giving these dances in this room would
seems like Russian mobsters there's like
nothing in the whole room except just uh
do it like a couple couches some boxes
and that's it and just the lights were
damning the music was playing I was like
goddamn this life you know it's like I
was happy but um I got caught up in my
addiction bad you know I mean and that's
what led to the
alleged bank routers bank robbers I was
indicted on like 16 or 17 of them in
South Florida I was found guilty
when's a federal prison a few years I
got out of federal prison October first
last year went out with my friends that
night you want to go celebrate this
isn't that stepped outside it to hang
out them for like an hour
step outside for a cigarette before my
cigarette was done I already hailed a
cab got in the cab and left didn't say
about it nobody or anything I said no
I'm not gonna do this I called my aunt I
said hey can I stay by you for a week
and go work at the temp agency and I'll
give you uh and maybe you know you can
give me the money I worked for and you
can go pick up my check and sign for it
over to yourself she's like yeah of
course no problem so I worked a week at
the temp agency bought my ticket out
here and I had two hundred fifty eight
dollars left in my backpack and Here I
am a year later so you came to LA for
did you have any no use nothing just
came out here just came out here and now
you're on Spiro
Hunt Skid Row
I'm everywhere ready for you where are
you staying really I try to stay in
Santa Monica it's a little safer you
know I've done this I stayed down here
in a tent for a few months it's like
there's so much [ __ ] you know
there's so it's but I think make Arthur
Parks a lot worse yeah you know I come
down here I know which areas to stay
away from you know it's like I know what
[ __ ] to expect to wear down here cuz
I've been down here so long or not even
that long but just I've gotten involved
in everything you know and but MacArthur
Park is like that sleeping dog you know
I mean you never know it's more
dangerous yeah because it's you the most
unexpected they pulled two bodies out of
the water out of the lake right there
this morning I'm watching that
you know last night there's helicopters
there's eight squads they're holding
some guy down he's a white guy in a suit
laid down on the street I mean I don't
know what he did but they were on him
you know it's been a wild ride out here
in LA my first two months I spent
running up and down the hill carrying
batteries and Printers making funny
money I don't know if I'm in Kermit I'm
not in yet know
allegedly and man carrying batteries and
cups of water and a guy I was working
with was a nut job he smokes so much
crystal he we do all this work to take a
whole week we get everything almost done
and all of a sudden out of nowhere
I'd smell smoke and I'd be like [ __ ] not
again and I run out and there he is
burning everything we did all of our
work all the money everything because he
had a they're coming for us he's been up
too many days and after two months of
doing this I mean we were making good
money like we would come up but he would
destroy everything we built because he
was wacked out of his [ __ ] mind I
mean I would go I would go down the hill
and go fill up like a 5-gallon jug of
water just so we'd have some you know
for cooking and drinking everything and
all of a sudden I hear these pops and
then be here and she flying through in
the bushes as I'm coming up the hill and
I'm like I'm thinking like this rats or
snakes going on then I realized sort of
bullets flying past me there's nut job
up there here's somebody coming back up
the mountain that's me you dumbass you
sent me down for ten minutes ago to go
fill up this jug of water you know I
mean so I had to get out of there
because I was an accident waiting to
happen you know I mean but uh
so your dad is still around yeah I I
haven't talked to him in like six months
I miss him I love you know I miss him
mom
Chicago or New Jersey
I haven't talked to them in like six
months I called my sister a week ago and
the first thing she cuz I owe my phone
right now
and she's just like go to the AT&T store
right now I put on my plan you need a
phone so I can get in contact with you
and I would say TT store and I needed an
ID and I haven't talked to them since I
haven't talked to her since I know I
should but I feel so guilty you know
what I mean cuz I should be there cuz I
love them more than anything but uh I
don't cuz my habit is off the [ __ ]
chain you know I mean I'm like I do fat
ice I shoot and smoke fentanyl is that
your drug guy yeah like your heroin
doesn't do it yeah and it's like $150 a
gram I need at least a gram to be
functioning and anything more I'll be
happy you know I'm saying like my fence
where I bring my stuff that I'd come up
on and they buy it for me
she she knows like or used to be $20
will fix me from being sick but $30 will
make me smile like there's no English
what how much do you spend a day now
about 150 to 200 a day
and what are you doing for money I find
things
and result yes
yeah find things and resell them not
from people personally because I'm not a
dirtbag I don't come up off of people
but if it was like a business or a
company for some reason and I feel like
that's the lesser of the evils no it's
not right
but that's my reality if you have a
faster way to make a hundred dollars in
two minutes please tell me because I'm
well we'll be very open to that you know
what I mean
but it's like I've tried the working
thing and it's like by the time I'm done
working an eight-hour shift I'm dope
sick and cuz me moving and round so much
works all the drugs through my system
and it's like okay I just made almost a
hundred dollars for eight hours when I
can go walk into a store and make a
hundred dollars in 30 seconds I swear to
God you know so it's like I know I've
counted on that it's a pace for some
things so it's like and now I've been
stuck into that you know I'm saying like
I met these two girls who went to USC
and they worked at the bars down here in
LA and I thought they'd be slow she
called me I go over there hang out then
she owned a gimme drinks and stuff and
one day she walks by she said feels a
big stack of credit cards which is like
look at how stupid people in LA they
forget all their stuff and I'm like Amy
gimme gimme you know so I was making
like 1100 to 1500 dollars a week on that
and all of a sudden she she transfers
she goes study abroad and now I'm I
thrown out into the chocolate with this
monster habit because I'm making all
this money and I have no hustle now so
what do I gotta do I got to figure
something out
you know what I mean so it's been two
months I figured it you know I mean I've
I'm sustained where I'm comfortable and
I can count on it but I can also count
on the fact that I know my days will be
numbered because I know with my
lifestyle and this fentanyl I'm gonna
end up in a box
whether that's above ground or below
you're still looking for clean what you
still look really I tried my best
you can pass her not being at it ya know
if I go shower and clean up all my hair
bag you do not work hard sure you fit in
Santa Monica burger that helps me fit
into places so I can do what I got to do
you don't want to walk in there looking
like a [ __ ] because then your doctor
gonna say get out of here or watch you
you know mean so you kind of got to
blend in
I've learned you know you have kids of
your own
no no kids you stay clear that that's
good
yeah and what's your what's your plan
down the road do you have any plans I do
I'm mom
I need to get
I need to figure out what I'm gonna do
about my addiction because it's like I
love to get high I love it
like I love getting high it's like a
warm blanket on a cold night it's my
happy it's it's sad to say but it's my
happiness yeah and I need to figure out
a way to substitute that with something
else because I know I could be doing
more I'm worth more wasting my life you
know I'm saying it's like if there's a
way for me to balance this my first plan
by short okay my short-term goals I need
to get into a methadone clinic
I know methadone's not good but it's the
lesser the evils it's gonna keep the
[ __ ] needle out of my arm and it's
gonna keep me out of these stores doing
dumb [ __ ] yeah prison jail beyond no I
mean detox in a Cell with some idiot you
know what I mean it's like there's no
they don't they don't care could you do
it on your own no I couldn't there'd be
no way you can drop me off in the desert
or the jungle take away my phone my
money everything to cell phone' guess
what I'm gonna be high I'm gonna figure
it out all right thank you so much for
coming by hi buddy